e os melhores sustos e reações
feito isso eu sinto os teus pais não têm
dinheiro para pagar a internet no
próximo mês por acaso eu não há problema
Acabou de sair uma aplicação que faz
todo o trabalho por ti leve tu
agora corre baixa todos os vídeos que
gostas Antes que fique estender
Você pode baixar todos os vídeos em
músicas em HD e ultra HD tem mais um
aplicativo
que sim isso é um anúncio é para comprar
alimento e água potável para os meus
filhos Leite link da descrição pessoal
aqui quem fala é o Dark Zeus o raio eu
posso ele já voou
e ela vai aparecer olha lá então dá
muito medo vestido meu Zap é [ __ ] e
[Música]
a
atenção o meu rápido senão não sai do
jogo Então
é só um saber lidar vamos sair daqui
agora é tua
funciona
tava no fluxo avistei a Novinha no Grau
sabe
o que ela quer falar levar você
tomou umas vai virar um
E aí
[Música]
E
aí já tava vindo um chá de dorgas Pronto
agora ai [ __ ] vai ai ai ai
ai ai ai
tudo bom
[Música]
[Risadas]
E aí
[Música]
A
Bruna
não tá bom
E
ai o meu cu e o meu cuzinho gostoso está
apanhar frio nesta Floresta assombrosas
quatro Pessoal vocês não sabem o que é
que eu encontrei hoje aqui no estúdio
fez não só é
um unicórnio Mágico
bom então esse é o Unicórnio
está funciona nada eu acho que eu tô
aqui dentro do
[ __ ]
chave meu Deus espera aí na porta já
tenho
que
abrir a porta do meu estudo e vocês nem
sabem o que encontrei não vou dizer seus
curiosos aqui ó
ah ah não ainda não mas
[Aplausos]
[Música]
já mas eu acho que eu acho que sim outra
vez que Cala a boca não quero saber
de uma coisa que ninguém sabe só eu só
eu
a sme
[Música]
surra de pal mole bi
bilada
[ __ ] não gostou não é não é
e tu é que vais para o outro não
[Música]
[ __ ] e jotapeg
pessoal daqui quem fala outra
o cara essa música para marcar os filmes
documento não eu soubesse muito tempo
música Ao contrário se vocês vão ver tem
a música o vídeo já é verdade poeta
no telefone sem fios atenção os
trabalhos Olha aí fica
[Música]
e agora tá na hora de casa comigo para
[ __ ]
subir
[Música]
viagens
segunda-feira e
[Música]
Oi tá fogo Como assim Isto é possível
e agora preparem-se para o concerto
final Olha só no que deu outra vez olha
mais uma vez Episódio 2 Ok
é só instrumental era agora vem a voz e
agora foi a voz
32 como vai produção
pode usar a